the guys beat here so I was looking
through the gaggle a game of Thrones
Season seven alerts I get each day and I
notice various different articles about
the Psalms a quote at the end of the new
trailer apparently people are
speculating that it means one of the
Starks are going to die their season and
some of the articles even go as far as
to say John will die so I decided to
make a short video to talk about the
quote itself where it came from in the
context of where it shows up in the
books there's really no spoilers here
because it's a rebuttal to speculation
based on stuff we've seen so I'm not
going to talk about anything that would
be spoilery first things first we have
to go into the source material here and
then I'll explain a theory that I've
been kicking around that since I've been
watching all the stuff that's come out
between season six and season seven the
quote actually isn't from Santa herself
it's not a Santa original if you will
the quote comes from her father
Eddard or Ned and he says it in the book
Game of Thrones to Arya it happens when
RA is nine and she's upset about the
direwolf lady and her friend Micah the
butcher's boy who were both killed she
locks herself in her room after not
eating her dinner so Ned has to go talk
to her
long story short after they talk about
where she got her sword needle and how
she had to throw rocks at nine area to
get her to run away
Ned delivers the line he says let me
tell you something about wolves child
when the snows fall and the white wings
blow the lone wolf dies but the pack
survives summer is the time for
squabbles in winter we must protect one
another keep each other warm share our
strengths this stuck with Arya so much
so that she thinks of it later on during
her adventures away from her family in
the second book A Clash of Kings it
comes to her while she's at Harrenhal
where she's basically you know serving
girl for Roose Bolton long story short
here she's thinking of running away so
she's out out and about and she kneels
in front of
the art tree there and ask the gods what
to do while she's listening she hears a
lonely howl of a wolf and then it's like
she hears her father's voice say when
the snow falls and the white winds blow
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
so she remembers the exact same part
that we hear songs of saying not all the
other stuff but it's really not
important at least at this point because
she's thinking about you know her
connection to wolf said to her wolves
blood basically you know the blood of
her family the blood of her father the
quote comes up again in a feast for
crows and at this period she's
travelling to Braavos and then it comes
up then and it also comes up after she
starts her training here the meaning or
at least what she thinks about when she
thinks about her father's words is
starting to change at this point in her
life she thinks that the pack is dead as
far as she knows pretty much everyone
she loves is dead or gone so she starts
to think that her father had it wrong
and that she as the lone wolf has to
survive fast forward to the current
state of things in the show she's left
for all those killed Walder Frey and
from what we've seen is headed north
towards Winterfell more her but her
family is still alive than she actually
realized and they are back at Winterfell
or in the case of bran
he's on his way we have to believe that
she would have renewed faith in what her
father had told her at this point so
that's the origin of the phrase and
where we're at Jon and Sansa are
currently holding Winterfell Jon is now
the king in the north like Rob was
before him and as we saw in the winners
here trailer bran is on his way there so
does it matter that it's dawn to saying
it or who if anyone she might be saying
it to well sure but honestly we can't
really figure that stuff out it's a
voiceover and there's no extra clues to
say who or what is going on you know who
she's saying to her what's going on at
that time theoretically it could be a
trailer only thing that they recorded
for the trailer I mean I
really think that but that's possible as
well but regardless you know I mean it's
in its mixed into those two trailer and
you know they're not trying to give much
away they're trying to piqued our
interest right so here's where my theory
comes in and I have read a little bit of
this coming out and some of the stuff
that people are writing which gives me a
little more confidence that it could be
right what I think is is it's
misdirection sure they have words over
what looks like an injured John riding
off alone north of the wall and they
have been having sophie Turner
you know discussing all this stuff in
interviews about sonses darkside and all
this stuff and they've been kind of
really trying to put that out there that
there's maybe some tension between John
and Sansa and that there might be some
tension at Winterfell between the Starks
but think about it a little bit I mean
last year what did we hear the most
before the season we kept hearing that
John is dead and while that was
technically true what most people were
concerned about was not whether he was
dead but whether he was going to come
back and I think a lot of people who
read the books really kind of got the
idea of how important John was by the
time he died but as far as the casual
viewer was concerned I think that there
was some definite skepticism about
whether he might come back or not so you
know they really put that out there when
the trailers came out there was no John
because there couldn't be any John he
was dead so on and so forth so so way
back when right out there season six
ended that was the first season seven
video that I made was about the fact
that they were talking about this
tension between John and Sansa and I
keeps coming up if you look at all the
articles that sophie Turner's done it
just keeps coming up that maybe
something's going on maybe Santa's
really enjoying a little bit of power
she's getting now and that she you know
they're basically making you think well
would she take over or would she try to
take over whose side is she really on
but if we look at the context of the
quote where it came from and then I mean
because this is honestly I was
completely surprised when I saw this
that people thought that because when I
saw it what struck me about the quote
was is that
a little finger we know we'll be trying
to put a wedge in between the Starks
that's what he does he wants to be with
Sansa he wants her power he doesn't like
John being named king in the north and
when we saw all that at the end of
season six right so the way I
interpreted this at the end of the
trailer was that it was sawn -
reaffirming not the Starks have to stick
together
that's what Ned said that's why he said
it and even though he didn't say it's a
song so she was involved because her
little sister was really angry at her so
you know I don't know where it comes in
like I don't know if I comes back and
she says this and then song two repeats
it's a little finger later I mean I
really don't know any of that but what I
do know is is that I don't think that
any of the stars are going to die
especially John because they can't just
kill John every so often and expect it
to have any meaning so my thought is
just that salsa is saying that because
yeah they might drift apart under the
influence of Littlefinger but in the end
they're all going to have to work
together just as the family's outside of
Winterfell are going to have to work
together against this threat the Starks
are going to have to work together
because the lone wolf dies but the pack
survives so they need to be a pack right
let me know what you guys think please
like the video if you enjoyed it I am
planning on putting out a spoiler
version of the trailer breakdown so be
looking for that make sure you subscribe
and tick the little bell there so you
get notifications because there's going
to be plenty of Game of Thrones material
coming out on the lead up to Season
seven thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon